ん
やす祖母というのは非常に珍しい名字でして安心の案に行かと書いて安床と言います
どうぞよろしくお願いします
1956年2月生まれの今59歳です
頭ですねスケートパークというスポーツ施設を経営しております
16歳でローラースケートのプロを目指して
43年間ローラス系統に関連する仕事をしております
今日はですねこれまで自分が経験したことやそこから得た
テーマなる人生ということについて話をしたいと思います
僕の息子はですね安床ブラザーズといいまして長男が
今31歳です二弾私と言いまして
28歳です2人とも今結婚して僕はの孫を持ついわゆるおじいちゃんなんですけれども
まあそういうやストプラざーずというのが今から20年前
1994年アメリカで初めて
林ラインスケートの世界大会が行われまして
翌95年にまだ幼い息子2人をアメリカに連れていって世界大会に参戦させたっていう
ところから
まあ今
僕の人生というかそういうものが始まったわけなんですけれども
1999年それからですね4年後にアメリカのサンフランシスコで行われた
この業界で一番大きな x ゲームスという大会で長男が金メダルを取ってそれ以来
16年間
常に兄弟のどちらかがトップに立つという結果を出してくれております
そうのおかげで多分今僕はここの上に出させていただいているんだろうと思うんです
けれどもそれではですね
まず彼らがやっているビデオを見ていただきたいと思います
t
car
dj
$ ha
ます
he
tan
me
hey
ええええええええええええっ
tan
yeah
par
car
yeah
ana
me
goo
yeah
teame
いいいい
anas
wh
me
yeah yeah
ha
car
dj nao
ます
tee
ハイあの試合会場に行きますとね
よく質問されることがあります
どうしたら
息子やそこブラダー図のような選手に育てられるのかっていうことなんですね
で
まあ僕はね正直言ってよくわかりません
これがあの努力と偶然が重なった結果なんでそのこういう風にしたらこうなるよって
いうその答えを持っているわけではないんですね
ただですねー
モチベーションをいわゆる勝とうとする意識
頑張ろうとするその意欲っていうようなものっていうのは僕は
その人が持つ価値観で決まるのではないかと思うんですね
結局違いとかまあこれねお金の山にならないですまあもちろん商品は何百万か入るん
ですけれども
こんな危険なスポーツで
それぐらいですもう一番大きな試合デー
東京な試合じゃなかったら何十万とか何万とかぐらいの賞金首が出ないわけですね
でもよしやるぞっていうそのモチベーションっていうのはやっぱりそれまでずーっと
培った経験とかそういったものを呼ばれるか時間がそうさせる
だろうなと思うんですね
で
僕は息子たちにちっちゃい時からよく言った言葉っていうのがありましてそれはですね
今は目の前にある一番大事なことをしなさい
っていうことなんです
このまもちろん学校に行かなきゃいけないしね他に友達と遊びたいとかっていうのも彼
らの価値観のかにはあると思うんですけどやっぱり国のか時間的にはもうそんなことが
やろう
お前は世界一なん票になるためには世界ちゃうなるためというよりも世界に通用する
スケーターになるために
これぞのアカンやろうっていういわゆるも僕の価値観の押し付けなんですね
そういうふうなこと僕はもう当たり前ずっとやってきたので
息子たちのその意思を尊重するとかそういうふうなものはもうほとんど無視してきまし
た
で
ある時にもう彼らが大人になって
のチャンピオンにえもーなったっていうふうなことがもう何回も何回もあるよな
今になってですね彼らは
そのことをどう思ったのか
あるテレビの取材でインタビューに答えたらことがあるんですけれども
その時にですね息子はね
あの時は一番いいや
はそれこそですね夜通し練習
僕が思ったような結果が出なければもう次の日学校はある
ない関係なくも夜通し練習で当然朝までですから
次の日学校行けるはずもありませんそういうようなことをもうずっと繰り返したわけ
ですね
で a
まああることが一番やった
そうやけど
あれがあったから今がある
っていう風に一応
結果が出て評価もしているわけですね
だからそこのバランスっていうのは親がどう判断するか
当事者子供がどう判断するかもし結果が出てなければおそらく悲惨な
安床気になってたと思うんですね
まああの未来のことは分かりません
でも目の前にあることを一生懸命にするっていうのはその姿勢は変わらないです
自動車
理屈や理論ではダメなんですね
身をもって実践しなければその説得力はありません
こうしてね話を進めてると
次子供の育て方っていうところにスポットを当てられがちなんですけれども
重要なのは
子どもをどう育てた花っていうことではなくて
育てた人間はどういう人物像なのかという言葉ですよ
これにてるようで
少し違います
その人間まあいわゆる安床ブラザーズ化してみると親の僕になるんですけれども僕と
いう人間はどういう人間やニット
いうことがまあ重要になってくるわけですね
選手を育てるには2つ
環境を整備する必要があります一つは練習する環境
二つ目はそれを発表する環境
練習をする環境というのがより充実してれば
実力を上げていきますでもそれがを発表するかが地域なのか
日本国内だろうか世界なのかっていうことで
彼らのモチベーションというのは変わります
世界にずれて言ってやるっていう環境を指導者が
ハス私作ってやること
まあ重要だと思います僕が22歳の時に
大きな木点がありました
まだ独身ですその頃は
大阪
中央市場で魚屋で働いてたんですけれどもその時に
僕の仕事というのは朝一時に起きて
地方から来たーー
トロ箱ですね
魚が入った木の木箱ですそれをトラックからトラックに積み替えるっていうのを毎日
毎日やるわけですね
単純労働ですでもしんどいです
眠たいです
そういう眠いしんどいつまらない
そういう仕事をずーっとやってるときに肌時がついたわけです
これ自分のトレーニングでしょ
だからその時に
heike た作業服をじゃあ人
長靴をジョギングシューズに履き替えてその作業をすると
まぁ今までみたいに振動やーみたいなことは無く
結構捗るわけですね
だから仕事をトレーニングにしようっていうその発想の転換でかなり気持ちが楽になり
ました
そういう経験があります
で
ここでですね皆さんにちょっと考えていただきたいことがあるんですけれどもそれは
テーマなんですけど
テーマというとテーマソングとかテーマパークとかまあ色々ありますけれども
テーマと一体何な
それは行動や創作などの基調となる考えていうか事情になっています
主題
僕はですねこだわりだと思うんです
これもですね以前1994年僕は38歳の時に台湾に行きましてそこに故宮博物院と
いうのがあります
ここには中国の大陸の放物 the
たくさん展示されているんですけれどもその中に象牙の一本彫りでた総合 q どれも
ありますた送球が多い層の魂と書きますそうた送球
14戸象牙の魂の中にずーっと玉が入っているんですけれども
そのどこ湯に作っているかというのも不思議なんですがなんとこれ120年かかってる
んですよ
もちろん一人の人間が作れるわけではあります何台の何回もナンダンガンでもかかって
この象牙の一本彫りという繊細な象牙を細工した
作品完成させているわけですね
動くはするみましてね
俺にも何かこれで県からん
思ったのが今まで16歳からずーっと続けたローラスケートあっこれや
よし俺のテーマ
スケートに所
suke 度にこだわっていくよ
っていうことでやっぱり儲かる仕事でありませんので
辛いことも苦しいこともあります
を辞めようかなということもあります
でもそういう時に
スケート礼儀ていくんやっていうテーマを持ってますから
頑張れるんですね
なんか石にかじりついてでもみたいなあかん時にどうやったらようなるやろって考える
わけですよ
もしこれそういうテーマがなかったらアカンなぁ転職しようかなあっていうことに多分
あってたと思うんですけれども
まあそういうことで僕にとっては
た早期うっていうものを見たときに自分のテーマというものがはっきり分かって
へ
おそらくみなさんもそういうテーマというものを見つけて持っていけば
未来が明るくなるんじゃないから
っていうふうに思います
まあ僕のテーマスケートと言いましたけれども
安床という名字を名前を言えばあのスケートのやつとか
スケートといえばおやすと恋の方がいうふうには世界デー
皆さんが認知してくれればいいなというふうに思います
デイバー持つことで生きる目的がはっきりします
こんなことが起こっても強く受けられますブレない
人生が楽しくなります
みなさんも今一度
振り返って
きっと皆さんの中にもテーマというのを探せばあると思うんですよ見つかると思うん
です
そのテーマを持ってどうぞ未来を明るく生きていただきたいと思いますご清聴とも
ありがとうございます